with almost 500 sessions the next 2018
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to them all so if you didn't see
intelligent internet of things Google
clouds IOT vision then stay tuned
because here's the rewind by now you've
probably heard IRT is a big deal last
year the number of connected devices
passed the population of the planet this
year it's forecasted to be up 27% over
last year if these trends continue by
2025 IOT worldwide will be generating 40
zettabytes of data
what's the zettabyte it's a billion
terabytes so while I ot is awesome it's
becoming increasingly clear that IOT on
its own isn't the be-all end-all we need
smarts we need infrastructure around all
this IOT data in order to pull value out
of this glut that we've got this is
where Google steps in as an industry
leader in artificial intelligence and
machine learning we have the platform to
make sense of this mountain of data
while there's no agreement on hardware
protocols technology stacks we see some
common themes around IOT that we're
going to be pursuing through this year
and into the next I want to touch on a
couple the big announcement from cloud
next is that we've developed a new
product that will push the boundaries of
putting that intelligence everywhere
cloud IOT edge extends Google clouds
powerful data processing and machine
learning to billions of edge devices
such as robotic arms wind turbines oil
rigs Smart cars cameras so they can all
act on the data from their sensors in
real time and predict outcomes locally
we didn't stop at developing this
awesome runtime though we also announced
our edge TPU Google's purpose-built
hardware accelerator chip that enables
lightning speed inferences on the edge
all this running on a secure and managed
operating system Android things and soon
on Linux OS as well we're making our
cloud IOT platform server list by design
so that you can go from proof to concept
with hundreds of devices to productions
with millions of devices in days while
keeping entirely modular cloud IOT core
our IOT gateway is critical here to
touch on just a couple of things with
IOT core provisioning millions of
devices can be connected to cloud IOT
core with zero provisioning operations
we're working with select secure element
vendors to make this possible
high-speed scalable messaging
it will make control scenarios much
easier where you want to be able to
directly influence the state of your
devices from the cloud support for
gateway devices to represent a multitude
of less powerful or less secure
on-premise sensors all these features
being added to IOT core represent a more
robust scaling we've already in past
conversations talked quite a bit about
how Google's infrastructure is built for
security from the ground up
IOT core has continued that trend with
solid security in place using TLS to
encrypt communication and JSON web
tokens for authentication I want to call
out something that we announced it next
our partners over at microchip have come
up with an 8-bit MCU that provides a
hardware route of trust to securely
connect over Wi-Fi to cloud IOT core
being able to connect an 8-bit chip
securely to the cloud will change the
landscape of connected devices and
lastly I couldn't talk about Google's
vision for IOT in the cloud without
mentioning all the partners that we work
with as big as Google is we won't ever
have all the answers we rely on these
amazing companies to blend their
technologies with our cloud
functionality to create solutions that
solve the world's problems one device at
a time as well as working with all these
great partners at the end of May we
announced that Google's joining the
Laura alliance and were committed to
working with our partner network to
nurture this ecosystem together if you'd
like to see the full talk check out the
link in the description below and don't
forget to subscribe to the cloud YouTube
channel for more great next rewind
content thanks for watching
you
[Music]